this video is sponsored by established
titles
you can try to resist try to hide from
my face but you know but you know that
you can't fight the Moon Knight welcome
to the heavy spoilers show we are now at
the end of moon night and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down all of episode 6. it's filled with
Easter eggs comic callbacks and we also
want to talk about the rumors of what
could be happening next Bull spoilers
ahead and I know it's early so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
episode then check out now if you've
been following the channel throughout
the breakdowns then I'd really
appreciate the thumbs up one last time
and make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss our doctor strange breakdown
without the way thanks for clicking this
now let's get into Moonlight episode 6.
okay so first off I want to talk about
how the entire Journey throughout the
season was actually foreshadowed all the
way back in episode 1. Steven's fish
tank contained a number of items in it
and now knowing what we know these have
pretty much set up the entire series
there was the Pyramid of Giza from
episode 3 then a journey into a head for
episode 4 which could be due at the ship
in episode 5 followed by the Temple of
konshu and lastly the gates of Osiris
really great foreshadowing and this
Series has been filled with it also in
regards to the Moon throughout every
time it's appeared we've had different
phases of it and this all comes to a
head in the entry when we get Arthur and
Moon Knight having their final showdown
in front of a full one the episode is
titled Gods and Monsters which has a lot
of meanings this phrase has been used in
a ton of things including Elana Del Rey
song and also a 1998 movie starring e
McAllen this follow the director of
Frankenstein and the Bride of
Frankenstein in his last days just
before his death he watched his life
slipping away before him realizing that
it was the end in Lana Del Rey song Gods
are the people we wish ships such as
celebrities and public figures with the
monsters being drugs Temptation and evil
here it feels a lot more literal with
the gods being figureheads and the
Monsters being what both Harrow and Mark
were turned into by being their avatars
Harrow was of course formally conscious
and he spent the series in many ways
repenting because of what the God made
him do and also because he enjoyed it
can I tell you a secret I enjoyed
dealing out pain in your behalf come the
end of the episode he's tied up in
hospital with Amit bound to him and this
is why konshu orders his murder so that
the God is finally gone now the episode
opens fittingly with a song The End by
El Grant which recounts the closing of a
chapter but how love persevere has
passed this and that it doesn't really
end nice little comment on how Marco is
happy ending in the field of reads but
he decides to return to Stephen because
hey what is it love if it's not
persevering now we pick back up with
Mark where we left him after being shot
by Arthur Harrow interestingly Harrow
shot him two times potentially one
bullet for Mark and one bullet for
Steven this opening tells the opposite
side of the story whilst Mark was in
Duet and I love how you can see the
little tattoo on his followers wrist as
he Scoops him out at this point Harrow
teases towards someone else being in the
body which of course sets up Jake
lockley who appears at the end sorry it
had to be this way Mark Spector
Grand
whoever else might be in there now
Arthur leaves behind the garden Scarab
or mock but weirdly his followers must
have forgot Layla was there too as they
pretty much ignore that she was ever
there Harrow's death transforms into
having an ancient Egyptian act side
which slightly resembles the blade of
the one that Moonlight had in the comics
these ancient axes were common weapons
given to pharaohs and we learn in the
comics that omit's original Avatar was
in fact a pharaoh Leila gets down on her
knees and picks up the Scarab off Mark's
Body which is when we see Harrow's
Caravan heading out he pretty quickly
shows how powerful the staff is by
wiping out most of the police but one is
judged to be worthy so he gets to keep
his life we have theorized that omit did
just want people that were useful to her
cause rather than actually good souls
and this is why the old woman was killed
in episode 1 along with the homeless man
at the end of episode 2. this is
potentially because they would have
caused a burden rather than being useful
soldiers so umit probably took the
police out to demonstrate her power to
the one who is most likely willing to
follow now as for Harrow he's a far cry
from the comics in which he was a mad
scientist that carried out human
experiments he had no connection to Amit
or Egypt however his experiments did
focus on mummifying people so meh I
guess it's a fair old inclusion to have
that yeah like Fair old anyway Moon
Knight defeated him quite easily but the
show has done a master stroke of giving
him not only the doctor roll from The
Source material but also something more
it's important to bear in mind that the
purple blast we see are also pulling
from the dark dimension which is why
they're able to wipe people out so
easily now at this point Layla readies
herself to kill him but Tara wear it
takes over a body and reaches out to her
she of course is a guide in the
Underworld so it makes sense that she'd
be able to reach out to those Above This
sort of follows on from last week in
which Mark and Stephen asked her to pass
on a message to Layla now throughout the
series we've had teasers that Layla
could end up becoming the Scarlet Scarab
in the comics this Egyptian character
was called Abdul alfal and we know from
the passport that Layla's name is
Abdullah al-fali if other is to call her
his little Scarab and along with the
Scarlet scar off we also saw a Scarlet
Scarrow drawn on her finger in the
hospital later on in the episode she
ends up becoming tarot where it's Avatar
and she Dons this Scarab symbol which is
our first major fan theory that we
predicted just ignore the other 20 we've
got wrong yet look look over there but
remember we got we got that one right
now arriving at Giza Harrow wipes out
the geezers there aka the eniad which
gives Layla time to grab conchu all
these dead members leave the door open
for more avatars to come in and if we
get a second season then we could see
brand new characters being brought
across I'm unsure if they'll bring back
Midnight Man due to the death of the
actor playing him but if they decide to
cast another person in the role this
could be a future path they take now
this video is sponsored by established
titles one of the best and funnest gifts
you can give someone as many of you know
I'm from Newcastle which is on the
border of Scotland so am I Scottish in a
way how did you know there's a
traditional Scottish custom to have
landowners referred to as Lads Lords and
also ladies that's why I was super
interested in this project which allows
you to get at least one square foot of
dedicated land on private Estates in our
Delhi aberdeenshire or Scotland so if
you pick up a plot you can refer to
yourself as a lord whilst helping to
preserve the picturesque Woodlands of
Scotland it's a great way to help the
environment as well as established
titles we'll plan a tree with every
order they work with global Charities
like one tree planet and trees for the
future to support Global reforestation
efforts now that also comes with this
bit of an ego boost on top of all the
environmental stuff you can officially
change your name on credit cards and
plane tickets to call yourself a lord
also give you official official
certificate I Am Lord heavy spoilers bow
before me punk this confirms your
lordship and also the unique plot Number
showing the exact location of your land
Mother's Day is also right around the
corner so established titles have put
together an offer where you can claim an
additional 10 of any purchase I've
linked it in the description below and
all you have to do is go to
establishtitles.com heavy spoilers and
enter the code heavy spoilers at
checkout this will give you that
additional 10 off it helps the
environment and also makes you feel
really really impressive I bid the
farewell my fellow Noble and I shall see
thou in the next part of the video
goodbye Army is finally released and
like the legend she's much taller than
the other gods she also has the braids
that she had in the comics linking
nicely back to that the more she feeds
the bigger she gets and this is similar
to The Source material in which he was a
giant Beast ready to Feast on all that
hadn't lived a kind life becomes clear
at this point why Harrow has been
putting glass in his shoes and he's been
desperate to release her guy clearly
knows he's imbalanced I think deep down
he carried out this Quest because he
knew that if he served Amit that he'd
likely be allowed to live it very much
shows the hypocrisy in omit's plan as
she will wipe out those are unbalanced
but will also use them as a weapon if
needs be she keeps going on about how
she's here to bring balance and we all
saw how that worked out for my boy
Thanos finally Leila leaves Khan Shu and
he wants to enlist her straight away
interestingly he calls her his little
bug clearly trying to play on the fact
that her father called her his little
Scarab but not quite getting there now
Indigo makes it namely the Jeff Lumia
run it was reveal that konshu was the
biggest villain in Mark's life and that
he'd been there from his childhood
manipulating him behind the scenes
konchu had deliberately fractured his
mind in the hopes of taking over his
body that's why the speech at the temple
last week was so Arthur harrowing
because it was both Mark and Stephen
admitting that konchu had manipulated
them into a thing that no one would ever
want like an El muerto movie now in the
end mark and all his personas United in
the other void to crush konshu's head
which in some ways does sort of mirror
how his personas all come together to
defeat the big bad here the comic ended
with him finally getting the God out of
his life and he looked over the city as
the rain hit his face though he didn't
know if this was real or not he decided
it was real enough which was good enough
for Mark and the other personas now come
the end of the episode we see that
konchu's still manipulating the guy and
that he's now using Jake this makes me
think this reveal in the comics is
indeed true and we do get some teasers
towards it the way he acts with Layla
makes me realize he just cares about his
avatars and nothing else which is why
he's like well no doubt Mark died
fighting clearly just wants to replace
him and doesn't really give a [ __ ] now
can't you and Ahmed end up going head to
head but just before the fight Ahmed
says
been cruel to
indeed I cannot allow you to proceed my
guess is that he originally had flashing
feathers over his face which would be
similar to how he looks in the Legends
this is probably right away over the
years though giving him more skeletal
look back in the field of reads we find
Mark and Tarot which I'm sorry how much
I keep butchering that I'm I'm really
just I can't get it right and I
apologize for that now his heart is full
and he's finally at peace without the
chaos that dominated his life however he
can't rest because Steven is out there I
love the line about how he's manifesting
everything around him and in the Legends
the field of reads was someone's
idealized version of their life Mark
imagining his having to be like this
shows how destructive his life was and
just in the same way that he manifested
Stephen a coat with his mother's abuse
he's manifesting this paradise to rest
but can he rest nope he refuses to leave
Steven behind and he exits the field
which transforms around him Mark has a
heart to heart with Steven's corpse and
refuses to abandon him and he freezes up
as he places his perfect heart in his
hand which frees Stephen along with him
in the comic says a moment the pair
hugged each other and this brought them
together completely which this scene
symbolizes too they now share a full
heart instead of being divided which
opens up the gates of Osiris and allows
them to travel back through I was kind
of predicting that an external force
would be the one that got them out there
like Jacob can't you but I actually
prefer that they escape themselves
sensing that he's alive konshu once more
resurrects him which is something that
has happened several times in the comics
every time Marcus died konshu has
brought him back another transformation
is a bit iffy effects wise with the
blowing head it's a nice way to show
that Moon Knight has returned I do
really love this suit and along with the
Mr night one they make a new deal with
konshu he promises to release them both
and with the any AD no longer judging
him he's able to turn back the night sky
at this point moonai jumps into the sky
creating an effect over the moon that
looks like a crescent one really nice
imagery and I feel like it's ripping on
the shot in Batman 89 in which the
Batwing flies up over it too Layla
finally becomes terrible hippo ladies
Avatar and we learned that her father
was taken to the field of Reed so that
he now lives in Paradise that's a bad
outfit God damn I just kind of wish the
CGI was better as it is a bit
distracting when she opens up her wings
there's a lot of movies being delayed
now even though Cinemas are open and
this is actually because there was a big
backlog in bfx so I just don't think
that the audience have had enough time
to fully polish things like this it's a
real shame as it did kinda take me out
of the moment even though I know these
guys would have been pushed for time and
trying their best now Moon Knight flies
to the pyramid and he battles it out
with Harrow on the side of the structure
this shot has been used heavily in the
trailers and I love the way that they
tilt the angle on the camera so that the
pyramid is sideways it creates a lot of
smaller sideways pyramids begging for a
really cool shot flying through the
night sky mark jumps back and forth
between himself and Steven showing that
they have now fully accepted each other
and that it isn't a fight for control in
the streets of Cairo they battle it out
whilst omit and konshu have a Kaiju
fight against the pyramids really nice
idea for a final battle that hasn't
happened in the comics before and it's
great that we get the guards going Head
to Head whilst we also have the ground
level fight I love the constant Persona
switching even if we get the little
corny bit you know the corny bit where
Marvel has to hammer home that they
indeed have an Egyptian superhero now
but representation is important and this
is probably gonna mean a lot to little
kids who are finally seeing themselves
in a superhero so I'm just gonna avoid
my 33 year old cynicism and be like meh
you know what good for you I'm an old
person and the kids are probably like
this now Mark gets stabbed with the
staff and at this point we get another
blackout like in episode 3 to find him
on the other side of it in a position of
power I did theorize that Harrow would
have him beat and that the Jake Persona
would come out but I was expecting us to
have that as the introduction rather
than the blackout that we get here a
jake luckily was someone we've expected
to see for a long time and there were
lots of Clues throughout the series to
him Adam coming up this actually has
major bases in the comics as Mark
explained to Stephen that though they
met in his childhood which we saw play
out Jake didn't arrive until so much
later on Jake is very much a way to
protect both Stephen and Mark when
things get too tough for them which is
why he ended up killing those people in
episode 3. episode 1 of course had the
date scene which I doubt mark would have
arranged because he was still married to
Layla and though he was attempting to
get a divorce it was to protect her and
it's clear that he still loved her it
was then the action change in episode 3
which also came with a Chicago cap
looking for Central sarcophagus
hello what the hell are you doing here
the action change it was also later
featured in episode 5 during Harrow's
office
you know I I feel real I feel like a
real doctor
also Harold brought up how he'd been
starting fights in the hospital which
didn't really seem like something either
Mark or Stephen would do there's also
been tons of Reflections in the series
and the vast majority of these have
featured two extra people in them
there's the museum glass which had two
people in the mirror and Steven's
apartment and the one in the Triangle
when he woke up that all foreshadowed
Jake being here now I'm so glad that
they have him in and though it is a bit
of a cop-out to have the angle switch
all of a sudden it's nice that they have
this looming mystery still hanging over
everything the newcomer audiences will
still find some excitement in back at
Giza they call on the gods to trap omit
and she becomes bound to Harrow
instructed to kill him and the god Mark
refuses and he's released by conchu
however come the end of the entry we
learned this as a [ __ ] lie and that
he still has a deal with Jake as of now
Mark and Steven are completely unaware
of him and it seems like he's the only
Persona who can take over the body at
will therefore I think that he's gonna
be able to jump into it without Marcus
Stephen ever knowing and they'll have no
idea that conchu is still using them
Jake also appears with hieroglyphics
under his collar further teasing towards
can't use control over him now upon
being freed Stephen and Mark go back to
the Asylum with Harrow the pair unite
and finally break free of the trappings
in their mind and they both wake up in
Steven's bed to the same song by
Engelbert Humperdinck that appeared at
the start of episode 1. I can't play
this like I did in that first breakdown
as Engelbert he bloody claimed the video
but a nice inclusion here now there's
also the two goldfish symbolizing how
the pair are now swimming in the same
tank he goes face first and though he
isn't with Layla he's clearly more
accepting of his other side now going
wild with it potentially this is all
still in his imagination and the power
actually stuck inside the head believing
it's real whilst Jake is out there in
the actual world the show has played
with our emotions at several points and
potentially it could be happening it's
something we've been over in depth
several times and I've milked it quite a
lot so I don't want to do your head in
by repeating every single aspect David
but it's the only way that Marx brother
Rowling could have drawn the one fin
goldfish unless Steven somehow managed
to find one exactly the same I love that
this isn't the current to it and this of
course has been something that's
happened in Joker 12 Monkeys and shooter
Island again it's a bit of a tenuous
theory that has kind of been debunked
I'll admit it yeah I'll admit it's been
debunked but I would love to see it if
it was revealed that we had so many
things repeating because they were
trapped in the fantasy whilst Jake was
actually out there coated the post
credit scene which takes place in
saikenwitz hospital this is a reference
to Bill psykinware too I'm so sorry for
getting all these names wrong who is an
artist that has worked on Moon Knight
before here we find a rubber ducky and
harrow in a wheelchair much like how
mock was this looks exactly the same as
Putnam in his mind but it has the yellow
filter over the top that Hollywood loves
to add to show set in Mexico however
when we pull out to the final shot at
the end we can see it in London due to
the gherkin he's escorted outside by
Jake who arrives in his classic cap from
the comics whereas in the source
material he was a cab driver here he's a
limo one and he Wheels Harrow out there
after killing one of the orderlies I did
try scanning the QR code at this point
about 30 times as well but with it being
at an angle my phone wouldn't pick it up
normally these all lead to a free comic
and if you manage to do it then make
sure you leave a comment below with what
issue you got the license plate on the
limo also reads spktr which is of course
Specter this builds directly from the
comics even down to that detail however
it belonged to Mr Knight rather than
Jake in the limo conch who sits in a
suit based on that Persona which also
popped up in the Lemire run can't you
tell Tim he has a new friend Jake
lockley who speaks Spanish the executes
harrow in the back of the limo and the
pair ride out to the Moon hanging over
everything now potentially all of our
grasp that the accent changes are wrong
and Jake might just speak Spanish going
forward he could very much also
represent his mother's aggressive side
and be formed because of this I love the
Moon that hangs over this final shot in
the daytime and typically Moon Knight
operated at night however this shows
that Jacob is an outbreaking free of
that and moving on to working in the day
and there is a lot to take from it now I
am kind of settled on the theory that
Mark and Steven might be trapped in the
mine with Jake running around however
this final shot in London shows they
could all be together and not aware of
each other so going forward there's
still a lot of things I can do with
moonlight and I'd love to see the
Midnight Sun series or movie coming soon
we of course have blade going into
production first which will likely pick
up the conversation between him and Dane
Whitman from the end of the eternals
this was also set in London so it's the
right place and right time for their
meeting to happen they ended up going on
to help form the Suns which Moonlight
was also a member of though they haven't
introduced Ghost Rider yet I'd love to
see him and I think they can get
together a great team of soups that
tackle Supernatural elements in the
Marvel Universe what I want to see from
the future of Moon Knight is that but in
addition to it I also need some closure
on the Royal Bushman storyline first
mentioned in episode 5 it's clear he
calls not only a lot of Anguish for
Layla but also Mark Bushman is the
perfect villain for next time as he
pretty much was the reason that Mark
ended up becoming country's slave and
he's also the person that murdered
Layla's dad he was originally supposed
to be in the series but Muhammad yab
said that due to his similarities with
kelmonger that they skipped over him if
we get more from the character though it
just makes sense to include him and yeah
that's kind of what I want to see if he
ever comes back which you better bloody
come back now that's what my thoughts on
this series I know I say this every time
and I've come to grips with the fact
that I suffer from recency bias but this
is up there as being one of if not my
favorite MCU Disney Plus show yeah Kevin
back back the money or back the money up
I've said it's good I think that the
series has not only stayed very
consistent but it's managed to improve
almost every single week and there's
been some brilliant moments that have
made me question exactly what's going on
Oscar Isaac has delivered some
phenomenal performances throughout and
we've laughed cried and also got a
globetrotting adventure that feels like
it's ripped right out of myths and
legends on the opposite side of this I
think Layla was an incredible addition
and in the comics I always found all in
a bit boring but may calamari which I
hope I pronounced right she knocked it
out of the park also let us know below
what we're gonna get more comments for
pronouncing May's name wrong or tarouwet
you get an amazing prize if you get it
right now in addition to this there's
Ethan Hawke who really brought his
A-game to the role he was intimidating
menacing but he also had his soft aside
when he was manipulating people that
made you realize how dangerous he was
all around Great Performances and now
the CGI suffered at points there was
enough good here that I just kind of
ignored a lot the flaws however I do
wish that they showed Moonlight a lot
more and though he had some big scenes
at certain points this was clearly more
about the psychological aspects of the
character rather than being an action
show I do like the fact that they tackle
deep themes like that but in an Ideal
World I think we would have got more of
a balance with these moments but also
some focus on him being a superhero I
think this might have a bit less
re-watchability than some of the other
shows but for a first journey it was
really well thought out now saying that
I might actually go back through the
whole series as there's a ton of
foreshadowing and I'd love to see how it
all pays off now unfortunately I thought
this episode was probably the weakest
one in the series and Marvel do have a
bit of a problem sticking the landing
with their shows outside of Loki I think
they've all ended a bit meh but I am
trying to judge the series as a whole
rather than just this one entry now in
terms of ranking all the Disney Plus
shows so far I would probably go Loki at
number one I love the multiversal
aspects of it the reveals were big and
there were also actual Stakes to it that
had great ramifications for the MCU next
is Moon Knight for the review I've just
given and after that is one division
which still holds a place in my heart
due to the week to week Journey everyone
had with that show I still don't think a
Series has matched the hype of it and
the production design on the old TV
shows was absolutely perfect after that
it's Falcon in the Winter Soldier for me
what if goes on from that and then a
talk eye last twitch though I enjoyed it
just didn't get me as hyped as the other
shows and when re-watching Daredevil I
realized that they kinda dropped the
ball all a bit with Kingpin so overall
great series with moonlight though and
and of course love to hear your thoughts
on it in the comments below we are in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of Spider-Man now a home on
the 15th of May and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you make the comments at random and the
winners of the last one on screen right
now save that to you then message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our doctor strange
theories which will be linked on screen
right now it's our final video before
seeing the movie so definitely go check
it out right after this by the way
thanks for sticking through the video
I've been Paul I'll see in the next one
take care peace